[Applaudissements]
c'est que nous sommes
voilà ça va non mais vous vous soyez oui
moi aussi j'aimerais pourquoi vous êtes
là le vendredi maintenant bah je sais
pas écouté on a fait un peu les 400
coups tous les mercredis baisser les
bras et vous savez benjamin cette
chronique c'est un peu la dernière
saison
mais votre saison à bout serait pas dans
tes pm pdt
possible
bon en tout cas j'ai décidé de revenir
sur les plus grosses d'un cas de cette
saison à commencer par nos potes les
politiques bien sûr qu'ils nous ont
offert une belle séquence dans le gauche
à droite
c'était une année présidentielle avec
des politiques qui se bousculer dans les
studios et à l'occasion de découvrir
plein de nouveaux noms accueil arnaud
robinet mélangeur
bonjour jean baptiste lemoyne
[Musique]
bonjour
l'année donc riche en interview
politique avec des journalistes toujours
hyper bien renseignés il n'y avait pas
la ministre britannique vous l'aviez
souhaité aujourd'hui je crois que vous
la rencontre est tout à leur nom
des candidats qui étaient pas vraiment
fan de certains prénoms ce qui me gêne
c'est qu'au bout de trois générations on
appelle encore ses enfants mohamed mais
je pense que ça a été une erreur aussi
d'autoriser les kevin hell et jordan
gens donnent bardella bonjour
si marquée par le coup vide et
heureusement que l'ex-ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer arrêter là pour nous éclairer
sur le protocole sanitaire r60 ont fait
un test à j 2 et la jcat ont fait un
autotest pour les coquilles maxi un
enfant a été contaminé une première fois
ça rend clanchin cycle donc là on est
mardi et le mercredi il peut faire un
autotest à la maison le jeudi et ensuite
à j-5 encore un autotest négatif pour
revenir mais ce que je veux dire
engage soutenu c'était le candidat qui
commençait à free un lien il a toujours
un langage extrêmement châtié ils sont
venus à assas avec iv qui avait envie de
faire une joute verbale efforts étaient
aussi de les corréler il faut arrêter
dit ces gens là sont des hurluberlus
enfin c'est bien beau mais quand il est
avec ses poteaux skyrock il oublie vite
l'académie notre bob je saigne au labour
verbal jugeant
extrêmement inquiet ces gens là sur les
hurluberlus que
[Musique]
les politiques se joindre à vous le
savez bas dont tu l'as vu il ya aussi la
télé un ba ouai cette saison on a vu pas
mal et je me suis dit que c'était pas
mal aussi de revient aussi sur le moment
qu'on a vu en tenue cette année le plus
gros
[Musique]
oui on pouvait pas finir l'année sans
parler téléréalité avait des candidats
qu'ils savent faire bonne impression dès
le début
bien approché dans les sciences au
contraire c'était l'amour fou entre ces
deux tourtereaux
où
c'est la fin de ma vie on va faire des
petits bébés
c'est toujours plus tard s'est terminée
avec châssis elle a décidé de retourner
au chaos c'est beau l'amour mais quand
j'ai besoin d'un petit shoot
d'adrénaline je veux mettre des
émissions avec des policiers pas
toujours claires sur leurs consignes
on a fait la rencontre de nos amis qui
travaillent au plus près des bêtes au 10
mai puis de touche à tout et fois
qu'elle cuisine et sert les produits de
ces élevages tous les midis dans ce
domaine je restaurant super concept en
tout cas j'espère que sa petite fille et
pas trois attachés au bachelor même
[Musique]
une année riche en actu avec des
journalistes de berthen y avait toujours
des questions très pertinentes questions
qui se posent comment ces avions qui
vont être envoyés par certains pays
occidentaux vont être acheminés vers le
trail
vous savez le gros avantage en avion
c'est que ça vole
et remet un petit coup de coeur pour ce
couple de retraités toujours l'air de
nous présenter son petit havre de paix
en gt1 au coeur une maison de charme qui
me ressemblait on l'a aimé tout de suite
et pourtant il y avait deux trains et
bien aux gens je me porte
je
vous sentez rien puis d'y poster de
belfin j'ai vu dans son honneur sur les
vaches et sur les stèles gamme de jeux
pour la famille shalit
si elle était au bord des larmes elle
ment jamais bien on s'est calé j'ai
goûté ça nous tient
il ya des coups qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a
rien dedans mais ça fait quand même un
gâteau
la magie de la cuisine c'est incroyable
ce beurre par l'huile de coco en place
les oeufs par la banane ou et ça veut
dire sur ça au monde sait que la banane
amusez-vous colaco que
[Rires]
benjamin chez que vous l'attendez ça oui
une séquence que vous qui ferait alors
c'est votre séquence préférée we ever
alors juste avant si je peux me
permettre je tenais déjà vous remercie
pour cette saison alors je défile pour
rien
on avait quand même pas mal de
chroniques ensemble et oui on a remercié
aussi cyril qui m'a donné cette chance
immense ça c'est plus sympa tu râles en
tête 2-1 pourquoi la
loi len évidemment qui on a fait sur
cette chronique tous les monteurs les
graphistes qui sont passés sur chronique
évidemment la direction de h2o abri
allez allez en avant comme ça qu'on
envoie la dernière météo des raisons
c'est parti
à bayeux c'est pas trop conseiller
d'imiter spider man dans sa cuisine va
ce mec avait quand même essayer
[Musique]
en
parlant de spider man on a vu en exclu
les toutes premières images du prochain
film seul pelé ruf
[Musique]
nous nous en souviendrons de ce gars qui
donnait pas mal de fil à retordre à son
père
[Musique]
pour éviter les coutumes à marseille
attention à pas mettre le chien trop
près du ventilo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
tout
le petit artiste avec des dessins trop
chou pis pour sam hamad al
akwa tier des ouvriers avaient trouvé un
petit passe temps bien sympa sur les
chantiers
est pour moi le meilleur dans l'année le
meilleur green bay restera solide ce mec
à sarlat
[Applaudissements]